and now tell us your feelings or
thoughts on the future of multi-format
tournament such as this one which has
either different time controls or
different types of play whether it be
Basque fish a random or others well I
think I think classical chest is at a
point where either either it's
completely fine or it's not okay at all
i think if you look at a lot of top
terms recently the draw average has been
going up significantly and I mean the
return I played in Bilbao lash or where
I think it was maybe her sari was this
year right it was this year I think of
something like eighty eighty-five
percent draws and I think even the same
field cup was somewhere north of 70 I
think so is that if the average rate of
drawers is going to stay that high than
I think classical chest is slowly dying
it's it's a lot more stressful but I
think it's interesting especially for
spectators to see different types of
play I mean you you get different
openings you get players trying to win
with black or trying or at least not
worrying about trying to dry the game
out trying to get an interesting
position in my opinion just tournaments
are going to go in this direction so
it's up to us to get used to them rather
than expecting things to be as they were
I think but if you're a little bit
flexible I don't see a big problem and
adjusting good I guess spectators they
really love it so you usually get a lot
of fighting chess and sometimes you know
if you mix in like fishermen and you get
chest which is just never seen at the
top level like we did last year with
with my match against immoral everyone
wants to see decisive games I mean
nobody wants to come and just see you
know see every game he drawn so I think
certainly multi-format and quicker
quicker time controls certainly are
going to be more relevant going forward